vous ne pouvez pas la louper au détour
d'une rue d'un carrefour dévalant à
toute vitesse aller partout c'est la
trottinette et dire qu'au début c'était
tout simplement un jouet pour enfant
c'est vrai il faut aussi briques et les
patinettes mais les adultes s'y mettent
aussi dès les années 1950 et certains
avaient déjà prédit la trottinette des
années 2000 en y installant un moteur un
repose-pied 4 roulettes un petit moteur
voilà peut-être comment sera équipé le
piéton de l'an 2000 c'est un peu
encombrant c'est simple et c'est
économique de livres aux 1000 km et
voilà le problème de la circulation
résolu c'est également un bon moyen pour
ne pas user ses chaussures mais peu à
peu la trottinette tombe dans l'oubli
enfin pas tout à fait certains
bricoleurs pare-feu lui tente d'inventer
quelques prototypes avec plus ou moins
de succès voici de patin ski ou
patinette des neiges
conçu par fabrice parisien c'est de
rigueur pour goûter à sa convenance des
fois de la poudreuse
l'engin comporte un système de freinage
il est pliable et se conduit comme une
vraie patiner vous préférez peut-être là
trottinent herbe
disparu du paysage urbain depuis une
quarantaine d'années retrouve une
certaine jeunesse en altitude mais la
trottinette urbaine revient en force au
début des années 2000 légère viable et
écologique les jeunes se l'arrachent
une nouvelle race de deux roues des
balles depuis peu les trottoirs de
marseille en omois la trottinette new
look a chuté de 1500 francs
elle fait un véritable carton surtout
chez les jeunes après les enfants c'est
au tour des adultes de succomber à la
mode de la trottinette
à tel point qu'une société de transport
a lancé un service de trottinette à
moteur à paris attendait cela ne vous
rappelle vraiment rien
[Musique]